Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre quelque chose pour bluffer les gens, votre entourage, tout ce que vous voulez !
Aujourd'hui, ou même dans la semaine.
Avec le sujet qu'attendent tous les mentalos depuis début janvier... l'hypnose !
Je vous avez promis qu'à partir de la fin de l'année, qu'on commencerait à aborder l'hypnose, et bien c'est fait, c'est parti, c'est aujourd'hui, mais oui !
Alors tu n'entends que le son de ma voix, et tu peux mettre, un pouce en l'air.
Dans cette vidéo, je vous donne deux trucs pratiques à faire sur quelqu'un pour bluffer une personne, sans avoir besoin de s'entrainer comme un ouf avant.
Mais durant les 4 mois qui restent avant le 31 décembre, on va aborder l'hypnose d'une manière un petit peu plus profonde.
Est-ce que vous préférez qu'on fasse plusieurs gros Masterclass, des choses de 15 minutes, qui abordent pleins de sujets en même temps, et qui vont plus loin ?
Ou est-ce que vous préférez des vidéos sur ce sujet là, plus souvent, donc plus courtes mais aussi plus pratiques,
qui mélangent un peu de théorie et tout de suite un petit peu de pratique, que vous pouvez appliquer.
Je vous mets un sondage juste là-haut.
Comme ça vous avez à cliquer et vous me donnez votre réponse.
On va dire, que vous avez jusqu'au 10 septembre pour me donner votre réponse et après j'étalerai un calendrier en fonction de ça.
Voici, pour vous, deux tests de suggestibilité.
Ce n'est pas si évident que ça à dire ! [rires]
Autrement appelés des inductions.
Lorsqu'on fait une hypnose plutôt de spectacle, ce sont des tests qu'on fait au départ, sur un ensemble de personnes, sur un groupe de personnes,
pour voir qui est le plus sensible, et qui réagit le mieux.
Mais si on prenait le temps vraiment de le faire individuellement, ce sont des tests qui fonctionnent quoi qu'il arrive avec tout le monde.
Le premier test, vous n'avez aucun risque, il est entièrement automatique.
Evidemment, vous n'allez pas le dire à la personne à qui vous allez le faire.
On appelle cette personne la, "le sujet".
Voilà, c'est parce que...
parce que c'et comme ça qu'on dit !
Vous demandez donc à votre sujet de mettre les deux mains comme ça, de les appuyer fortement l'une contre l'autre.
Et de croiser les doigts comme ceci.
Puis de bien bien serrer les deux mains.
Un fois que c'est fait, la personne doit redresser les index, comme ça,
continuer de serrer les deux mains, mais écarter le plus possible les index, comme ceci.
Quand votre spectateur sujet, ami, famille, je n'en sais rien, est dans cette position,
et bien, en tension, vous allez placer vos doigts de part et d'autre des deux doigts.
Donc vous avez les deux doigts qui sont comme ça,
et vous avez vous, vos doigts, et vos mains qui sont comme ça.
Et vous lui expliquez qu'il y a un boulon invisible entre ces deux doigts et que vous allez resserrer la vis,
pour faire en sorte que les deux doigts se rapprochent de plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus.
Et ces doigts vont vraiment se resserrer de plus en plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus, jusqu'à temps qu'ils se touchent.
Il y a un début de suggestion dedans évidemment.
Mais il y a aussi une partie physiologique qui fait qu'automatiquement
les doigts ne peuvent pas rester dans cette position,
si tout le reste est bien resserré, bien en tension.
Ils vont avoir cette tendance naturelle à se relâcher, à se rapprocher.
On ne garde jamais un muscle en tension indéfiniment.
Et ça, c'set ce qui va vous servir à asseoir votre qualité d'hypnotiseur du moment.
Car oui, forcément, quand vous faites un test comme ça, quand vous faites une induction comme ça,
vous devez avoir un discours très cohérent, et donner le sentiment que vous êtes très confiant en ce que vous faites,
et que c'est pas ça va marcher, c'est ça fonctionne.
Il n'y a pas d'autre solution.
Vous pouvez dire: "Mets tes mains comme ça, tu vas voir c'est une hypnose simple, quelque chose de léger, quelque chose de plutôt marrant,
croise bien les doigts, serre bien complètement, mets tes deux doigts comme ça toujours en tension.
Et regarde, si je place mes doigts comme ça,
sans que tu ne puisses rien faire,
je vais resserrer une vis imaginaire qui passe entre tes deux doigts,
les deux doigts vont commencer à se rapprocher de plus en plus..."
Rentrez dans le personne de l'hypnotiseur à ce moment là.
Un autre test de suggestibilité qui fonctionne bien.
Vous demandez à une personne de se mettre devant vous, mais dos à vous.
Vous lui demandez de fermer les yeux et vous mettez les mains sur ces épaules.
Et vous désorientez un petit peu, mais gentiment, très légèrement, un tout petit peu,
en lui demandant de toujours avoir les yeux fermés.
Donc d'avoir confiance en vous !
Vous placez vos deux mains sur ses omoplates, pour qu'elle ressente bien et le tactile et aussi la chaleur de vos mains.
Et vous lui expliquez, que au fur et à mesure que vous allez décoller les mains, alors elle va se sentir attirée en arrière.
Elle doit garder les yeux fermés tout le long, et vous faire confiance.
Vous décollez lentement les mains, mais le plus lentement possible, le plus lentement possible, le plus lentement possible,
et en répétant cette phrase de suggestion de:
"Tu te sens attiré en arrière, tu te sens attiré par mes mains, il y a comme un magnétisme entre mes mains et ton dos, comme une aimantation et ton dos est attiré par mes mains..."
Et vous prenez vraiment le temps de faire ça.
Le fait qu'elle est en plus les yeux fermés et qu'elle ait encore la sensation en fait du toucher de vos mains sur ses omoplates,
va l'attirer légèrement en arrière, de plus en plus rapidement.
Evidemment, mettez vous en position de la retenir !
Parce que sinon elle tombe !
Et ça ce serait dommage.
Voilà pour ces deux petites indictions du dimanche, qui va vous permettre de bluffer peut-être votre famille dès ce soir.
N'hésitez pas à vous entrainez un petit peu.
Quand je dis "à vous entrainez" c'est à parler tout seul de ce que vous allez leur dire.
Faites comme si il y avait quelqu'un devant vous et entrainez vous à tout ce que vous allez lui dire
pour ne pas vous retrouver sec, en train d'essayer comme ça pour les premières fois.
Et répondez au sondage pour que je sache quel format vous préférez, pour qu'on continue de parler un petit peu d'hypnose.
Dans le sondage, et puis bien sûr dans les commentaires, et même les autres sujets que vous aimeriez que j'aborde d'ici à la fin de l'année.
Je suis en train de prévoir toutes les vidéos.
"toutes les vidéos" je m'entends...
J'écris juste mes thèmes et mes sujets, comme on le faisait depuis le début de l'année avec le cahier.
Comme ça je sais que dans cette vidéo, j'aurai pleins de propositions de sujets que vous aimeriez que j'aborde.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir,
puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre.
Rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !